hello everyone welcome to another
session of st. Louis chess club place of
people today again we have our resident
grandmaster jessie cry to play in our
place so if you want to play against the
Grandmaster please challenge us on chess
calm so our we are the st. Louis chess
club so search for that name in the chat
on YouTube you should see a link if you
click it you can issue us a challenge
and we will play that people radio games
only no casuals radio games only blitz
time control so like five five zero
three two three or whatever maybe if you
want to challenge Jessie to bobollo game
he might accept he might not we don't
know yet so we'll see how he feels
who I'll see how it feels any any first
any word you want to say before we start
oh I'm pumped and it's a full on
streaming day you know those who watched
yesterday we had Allison from the club
upstairs she's been playing she got her
rating up to six almost 1600 I got the
club's rating up to 69 that's what we
want to see and they're gonna do they're
gonna do a bunch of ladies playing the
people after us
correct full direct oh yeah I'm on all
day so if you uh so it looks like we
have a challenger already so and this is
a tough tough tough man anyone so what's
our goal today what radiant dew point do
we want to get get to for today you
think mm I want a clean sheet okay I
want to clean all right now I hung a
piece yesterday and won that so I gotta
say that was pretty good now this man is
starting out unambitious but it doesn't
matter yeah it'll turn into a fight
alright so we have a viewer saying love
Jessie cry oh there you go
we'd love them too we love we love we
come come here
this mouse is a little finicky do you
want a new no I think some of this maybe
it's this Patterson it could be don't we
might have another mouse slip like
yesterday it was a tariff you won that
game too right at the end you came back
for that one uh yeah
so this is not your first time in saying
those correct you've been here many
times before yeah yeah several times
this is a very spicy moment by the way
oh he just declines the spice looks like
he wants to play it looks like he's got
a little spice going for himself too
this is interesting
oh yeah this is really interesting I
don't know who's better all right here
we go
I think I'm fully okay but this is
definitely spicy man carry you right
away I have to fight for my life yeah
thank your doing you'll be fine you'll
be fine
that's easy for you to say buddy it is
I'm just so uh I mean during your time
here you do anything exciting anything
fun you know no I know it's okay hey I
know typically when people come to st.
Louis
so like st. Louis nationally is known
for our art baseball beer because the
aunt anheuser-busch is here and then
hockey which is a blue so there's like
three main things of course like we have
like great parks museums all that stuff
haven't done anything huh uh not really
really you know I'm here to play chess
and stuff and uh man this guy's giving
me the business take it easy buddy take
it easy on me
I feel like well it wants bragging
rights yeah well I mean I'm just here
trying to have a good time try to talk
to you thing this guy is trying to give
me the business yeah he's trying to make
you think some Muir says French exchange
what a way to start the day
yeah really right I got a little time
invent this game's gonna I'm gonna
predict this is gonna be one of the
toughest rounds I want to see you play
against something like 2,500 2,600
you see how you do I'm not I'm not don't
put that kind of pressure on me man all
right it's got it he's got some he's got
an interesting position because he's got
this tension on g6 but honestly the
nights they don't do that much so he
needs a clever way to increase their
there you know mm-hmm their manliness
like that's okay does it do anything
though hard to say right oh I'm gonna
say it's not doing anything
hmm now Mayo nice move I like this guy
uh why why can't we see Jesse you can't
see me Danny Machuca what's the deal man
you gotta wait we were so you gotta wait
as always well first of all give a
shout-out to our man in the back Danny
Machuca dude I'm getting I feel like I'm
getting rolled here this move whoa whoa
whoa whoa what's going on here yeah
sometimes I'm a bad sport in these
situations I'm like they're cheating man
they're cheating
all right here we go I don't know if it
actually does anything let's see if it
does he does okay I see does he Howard I
don't know if it really does anything it
was it was beautiful there's no question
about that he's you gotta say he's got
some pressure for here
I feel like doesn't he just isn't just
the didn't just eat even is there any a
lot of pressure well it's more scary for
me no matter how how you looking at it
oh man this guy's really coming at me
you know I was trying to drink my coffee
and stuff here and then this guy is
treating me well I feel funny trying to
be it aggressive I know we always tell
our toe our kid kids that come here to
to be aggressive maybe taking that this
guy's taking it to heart nice
all right viewers so make sure you
challenge us on that link chest comm
link in the chat if you want to play
Jesse radio games only list time control
if you want to shout out a grandmaster
now it's the time to do it it's getting
spicy over here man the only thing is
I'm maybe I'm moving too fast as part of
my problem but I do have a time
advantage at least yeah well big time
yeah but it's three two so one things I
didn't grow up with this kind of fast
time control thing you know but one of
the things I've learned is you can play
forever right
you can play forever on this kind of
thing you guys have to solve some
problems right now though got a little
fork thread thing going on well yeah how
does he defend well here here it looks
locusts gifting me a pond okay shadow
Jack and I feel Phil that name is
familiar I guess one of the are one of
our regulars well um oh man I feel like
eius dodged a bullet there it was truly
a little spicy there for a second I
think when we go back he might find some
way to brutalize me totally possible
he's still trying to brutalize me it's
not very nice I'll tell you that just
keeps on attacking all right well oh
well Jesse's deep into that game a
reminder for everybody if you're in st.
Louis end of November we do have one of
our biggest tournaments of the year
Thanksgiving open starts Friday November
29th and it goes so Sunday December 1st
so we really for open tournaments we
really have I think nights 54 that was a
huge one that guy came at me you know
and one thing I've noticed about the
French exchange players is kind of like
they have violence buried in their heart
okay started out that way doesn't mean
that they you know don't know later
right because you think when your French
player you're like oh this guy's playing
for a draw or something usually usually
there's a hidden lion hidden in there
you know and it usually does it usually
just doesn't end in a draw that's my
experience that's why I'm no longer
afraid of it I like it
second game going on the quiz is 1861 so
ray training wise b22 only 100 apart so
we'll see how you do against the
grandmaster their giant googa oh yeah I
can close it here we got it got it all
right we fixed some technical
difficulties so we're back in back in
the game we have our second challenge of
the gauge giant googa cool this is cool
I so just recently iíve just decided I
want to start experimenting with this
Knight c3 move order it's the most
aggressive move order and for years I
was just like oh it's too theoretical or
yadda yadda but honestly when you play
we need move orders it's more
complicated to play with we need more
orders than it is to play the aggressive
things I think no iPad yeah because
there's just more weird lines and stuff
that you've got to deal with when you
play the weenie move orders right and
with this it's kind of this this
position especially is very theoretical
and known but honestly I feel like I
kind of sort of understand it
well I want to see see some some sex
give me something exciting games ah he
just brought that okay played a little
key six that's cool that's cool I don't
think these six was correct but maybe
maybe we can play this way maybe I'm the
one learner all right let's do what they
told us to do in school which was to
take and then push take and push I love
it all right
what was that before talking about oh
yeah okay so Thanksgiving open it is so
the club the Chess Club already only has
three or four big open tournaments every
year and st. was open I mean thanks gave
me open is probably the biggest open one
of the year we're capping it at a
hundred and fifty players because that's
really all we have room for and
typically we have around I think last
year was around like a hundred and
thirty-some something a lot a lot of
jams Iams play if you want to play
against some higher level players this
is the one to go to the entry fee let me
see here the mean make sure I got oh I
just want to get I got to get a
shout-out for my look at this next move
well you got em holy makes exclam i
don't know if there's an ex clam but
Holly anyway probably got both that was
it a bold move my friend that was bold
we have some comments from the back
peanut gallery Danny Machuca
yeah Danny but you could bet they're
saying oh this guy says he doesn't want
it well can I just take it then isn't
that mine isn't that in that all the
pawns belong to us no it's not Chuck oh
I thought it was check it wasn't [ __ ]
all right what's he doing to me bro what
does he want this one I don't I don't
know giant goo goo what's your plan
there tell us tell us all you strategies
you know what I'm just gonna bring this
night in cuz that's what daddy told me
to do
no this is this is the dream of this
opening not just to get the pawn but to
have the the niceness of all this stuff
and this pieces are kind of just like
spectators here BAM let's go just keep
on pushing up on up all right looks like
we're winning all the pawns in front of
your King John googa I got it all right
what's already now oh I don't know he
went up a little bit 17:44 1944 yes John
Google wants a rematch but I figure I
should play some yeah let's play as many
people different people as we can join
Google we'll get back to you if we have
time nin right nin Zoe
less accept names are we from
Switzerland love it love it this is my
new opening repertory that made me feel
good about you know playing that thing
here we go this might also new Knight c3
normally I figured I didn't do it
because I always felt I play this as
black and I was felt like this was just
an equal position and it is it surely is
an equal position however if you accept
the burden of playing this position you
get two you get the glory of playing all
the other easy things and maybe this is
a little bit better for the white back
in the day we used to call this equal
back in his pond you okay Matt Matt
Damon looks like Danny's uh give me a
little apology he's actually we're
saying right right right by us
and he's just a meal male why not play
on leeches it's because that's my jessie
cry prefers chess calm that's my fault
it's it's mostly because I'm an old man
and I and it's hard for me to learn new
ways that's
just a bit anyway yeah you get to do
whatever you want to here it's cool all
right uh uh what else what else what
else okay so we are Oh like Jesse said
earlier right so this this stream show
ends at 4:30 and right after this stream
in so we're gonna start another one
which is basically ladies play the
people and we have international master
dorsa direction coming into play the
people she is a current student and
chess team member as st. Louis
University and she also teachers our
ladies night classes here and she's
gonna play hopefully beat everybody that
challenges her should be a fun game so
tune in I'm actually going to tweet
about this you know in about five
minutes so you guys can see it follow us
on Twitter
they Facebook all that stuff you see all
the current and upcoming events for
everything boom he's tempting me but I'm
not gonna be tempted go back mr. rook
chasing you yeah push them back named
Zoey names and ends a week all right I'm
not sure about this next move boss but
I'm just gonna bring that night in there
and see if he can whatever whatever
feels natural play it you don't have to
think I think you know like I like those
bishops in the center that looks pretty
good yeah
now the thing I will complain about just
calm at least for this kind of event is
I can't I can't do my little arrows in
my little highlights hmm that's a bummer
man and I get it cuz I guess the other
person would see it or something if I
highlighted it I like this kind of
business would be fun to highlight some
stuff I feel like for as big as chess
comm is they can put in a feature where
you can put in the arrows and the other
person your opponent doesn't see it come
on chefs calm looking at you well if you
join us on the stream yesterday you know
that Jessie here it has a PhD in
philosophy
and we're gonna test some some up we're
gonna ask them some questions and see
how he feels with his background so our
man Danny in the back would kill me if I
didn't bring up the topic of genetic
engineering that's a big big thing
nowadays especially for him for some
reason I guess he wants to just uh for
someone that's he's he's yelling at me
from the back room yeah he's just
continue badly he's is like a gene drive
technology CRISPR we're gonna talk about
all those things
what hesitancy so one of our Zach
Belcher said you can use arrows you
might have them disabled go to settings
enable arrows then right click to add
arrows all right we'll try it when we
have a chance we'll try a that's pretty
cool all right we're gonna try that yet
all right so we actually had this
discussion with our executive director
Tony rich the other day about genetic
engineering so we're gonna see how Jesse
views this what do you use do you do you
do you think we should do you think
human beings
should experiment with genetic
engineering so we saw we already do it
yes the Edina corrected me we're already
doing it should we continue well the
only really intelligent thing I have to
say on the topic it's not even that
intelligent but is that so I read this
book that I can recommend on this topic
it's called the gene it came out by 2015
by a guy named Mukerji and you know I
what my takeaway from that book was was
that it's coming and it can't be stopped
so we can talk I feel like yeah we can
talk forever we can talk as long as
daddy wants yeah it's not gonna change
anything
this thing is coming and I think in
general I feel like all technological
stuff I can't think of one technological
breakthrough that people stopped do you
think it's um something that people like
okay we're done I see what you're saying
yeah we're just gonna not do it and so I
don't you know I don't see it been
getting stomped at all and it's kind of
I think throughout human history you
have what's going on in the world now
where it is it might be possible for one
group of people to say no we're not
gonna do it I think there was a period
for example in Chinese history where
they were like we're not gonna we're
done we're done in the ground I think
right on time of 1113 hundreds they were
crushing it and then at a certain point
they're like no we're making a group
decision we're not sure this is done it
probably wasn't a group decision is more
like coming for money
yeah now but any case right it didn't
matter that they stopped because
somebody else was gonna do it and then
like say now with I think another thing
it's very big and people definitely
should consider threatening is a facial
recognition technology okay right okay
and like in the u.s. we've kind of not
done it I think we're actually doing it
I think we are but let's say we stop
let's say we we decide to no well
knees are doing it everybody yes Chinese
are humping on that facial stuff so it's
like you know yep I don't that's just
for me so that's my two cents it doesn't
matter what you say about it it will it
will continue so if you if you had that
if you alone they had the soul like
decision of should we show the human
being population like should continue or
stop what would you say you means you to
continue doing the Chris birthday yeah
like obviously when you I mean if you do
it eventually it's gonna be to a point
where that's kind of the norm right
because if it's a certain percentage of
population became genetically altered to
be bette better than a normal mean
that's gonna continue no matter what so
but if you had the like you have your
hand on the button mean like we just
stop this do what would you do it I
think it's fun as a as a theoretical
discussion but you know the way I see it
it's like if I were in a position where
I was gonna die without the technology
obviously obviously I'm gonna do it you
know it's not even a question so we can
be purists about it and be like oh you
know not cool
but honestly yeah I think there's gonna
be situations where you're just gonna
end up doing it and I think that's gonna
be the situation going forward to is
what's gonna drive this is wealthy
people who have the means and a problem
not just some health problem that is
going to make it so they're going to do
it you know I think that's gonna change
so we got viewers saying Europe said no
to GMO okay okay that's like GMO is a
good example because when you look at
say wheat and you can't the fact that
we're doing it with the wheat means that
it gets infected the infects the worlds
crops because across hybridizes with
the you know other strains so for me
actually just another clear example of
how you know you're not stopping
anything they're not gonna invest true
you're not going to oh no
whenever we whenever this topic gets
brought brought up I always think to
like start to Star Trek yeah
we're like you know like the Geneva you
got you got Conn and his genetically
engineered team of people it's one of
those it's like it's like if there's no
regulations like that that's it's gonna
get to a point where yes I'm going to
start out by curing some disease but
then I start seeing the extra stuff you
could do mmm you know extra power speed
agility whatever it may be
brain power they're like it's just uh
if you take one step in that direction
it's gonna be everybody taking a step in
that direction yeah and this stuff with
like you know I think for example one
thing the gene book turned me on to is
let's just talk about chest for a second
right the when I was a kid and there was
a kind of there was a kind of story out
there whether it was chess or anything
else you might have been good at it was
like well if you try hard you will
succeed and the gene stuff is calling BS
on that claim right the gene stuffs like
no sorry but correct yeah this has
nothing to do with how much you care
about chess how much you worked at it
absolutely nothing sorry
it's a nice illusion and in a way it's a
cool illusion because it encourages you
to work harder but ultimately it's it's
kind of lame because the people who work
hard aren't gonna be necessarily
rewarded the correct another dream but
it's just like no it's not true
one of our viewers asked if you can play
E for opening with white sir I'll play
any for
this guy by the way is rated 814 and
even though I'm up with Khan and have a
nice position now I would say you know
it's not this guy's played a pretty
tight game 14 Wow okay yeah I never
really know if I've ever seen in a 40
however I think it's over now
and there's the fork he could maybe
throw in b4 of it and save a piece but
ultimately yeah
he played all right so in that you know
for example one thing with the genes
that's really interesting
for me personally as I just recently
started thinking say about my genetic
stuff when it comes to like physical
sports right hmm and I realized you know
they start thinking about genetic stuffs
almost everything human there's like a
bell curve right of of abilities yeah
and there's some people on the far end
to say really fast you know and I was
like I put myself on the bell curve
definitely slower maybe a little bit
physically like stronger and maybe
better with some indoor and stuff but
right there maybe just a little bit
better right mmm whereas then I see guys
who are really fast like I'm like I'm
not that guy I'm not the vast guy and so
that's really interesting because I
think also with physical stuff it's like
oh if you just trying hard enough you're
gonna be blah blah blah no I totally
agree with that you can't you gotta you
know your natural born of the ability
has to have play in there another thing
I was thinking about recently is like
when I was a kid I was never good that
good at drawing you know okay like I was
no I was just below Hafford when it
comes to drawing pictures or whatever
you know and I was also pretty terrible
I played a lot of basketball and I
practiced actually a little bit
and I was always terrible at shooting
okay and that to me is very similar it's
like a totally related thing where it's
about your fingers and that kind of just
light touch that you need in things like
basketball and other stuff like that
shooters tush get it I get it yeah do
you place worth now what do you uh you
know I need two for it right now I've
been running a lot and I before I had
kids I would bike a lot I mean I'm just
below average as a runner man I'm just
not built for it either I'm just not
built for speed you know I'm not a bill
to be a runner I I'm actually a avid
cyclist oh yeah when it's a well it's
getting colder now but I usually average
probably about I'd go riding maybe like
five five times five days a week and I
have about 25 miles a day oh nice yeah
yeah how'd it get in there yeah before I
had kids I was doing like ultra cycling
and oh I was pumped man really uh it was
I was the best shape of my life for sure
and the nice thing with cycling is it's
not what comparison to running which
running really is so much more about
speed even if you're doing a marathon
you kind of need let that jolt of speed
no but biking you can be kind of a
bigger dude and still you know do do the
big the big rides I think the reason I
got in the bike in the first place was
because running was taking a too big of
a toll my knees mmm I was just uh needed
something you know less joint well one
of the cool things I like to say is in
in terms of exercise you got it people
have three choices you can run in which
case your knees or your ankles or
something's gonna break you can ride
your bike mmm till you get hit I got hit
on the bike really one of the very bad
shoulder injury from the bike and your
third option is you can go
exercise in a gym in which case you lose
your soul yes I couldn't agree with that
kind of great of that there are certain
things that like it might be better for
you to do at the gym but like weight
like weightlifting it's probably like
you're gonna run on a treadmill I'm
never I could never stand out I could
never stand running out from them or
running on a stationary bike it's just
like yeah it's so sad and there unless
you go to some class where there's a lot
of pretty girls that's the only time
[Laughter]
yeah are you doing awesome love it I
think we're doing a lot of it I want to
see if this guy gives up do we need to
go the old-fashioned round I'm actually
checkmating we're gonna have to
checkmate this guy that's okay that's
alright we can I've learned how to do
there boom I did that love it
you know if funny thing I I was actually
I feel oh we got a sim who got a good
guy coming up I was never good
I was never good at checkmating if you
believe it or not super saying Danny
we're playing against the Super Saiyan
you need to get gave me the glow right
it's super seen oh he's going he's doing
this stuff to me man he's got a hidden
tiger in there he's got a hidden tiger
in there Oh check to them is Oh before
I've had this before bang and I was
supposed to go bang yeah I don't know
what he's what 2,200 little like that
I want our rating to go up yes this is I
had this I had no idea that this was an
actual thing but it turns out I think
that Carlson in some game maybe it was
even just a rap again played this weird
queenie to move and that's why if you
play the french you might see this word
queenie to move i think in a game that i
had recently i
the Queen e2 is the main move
now keep it simple yeah it's funny with
the books man yeah that's interesting
all right now I'm trying to keep it
simple over here too just to give every
a frame of reference Danny is telling us
stuff in the back about a book so they
can't hear they can't hear they can't
hear Danny I'm always trying to get
Danny they wear a mic so you can hear
him but he won't do it come out here
then if there you don't have a mic to
put on come out here come out here get
out of here
he's making excuses he won't come out
you make it anyways the gentleman ready
8 8 4 14 says thanks for the game this
guy is keeping it simple on me buddy
look at this he's working me yeah let's
see especially if you're an old man the
only the only way your ability goes is
down trying to improve as an illusion to
only damage you agreed I'm getting older
and my days are dying yeah I think I
cheat I'll say I think a lot of people
talk about their knees dying and I think
it's usually BS Lika I had some doctor
for example years ago tell me that I
just had to get used to it and that I
was dying or something yeah I know Yeah
right and it was total BS 2 totally
wrong that wasn't true at all
I got some pro troubles right here
though my friends I will tell you this
now it is not looking good for the job
oh well got some pins going on
I guess I'm attacked whoo that night
let's see here Adam
whatever whatever Danny is trying to
Danny say on the back great position
here dude he has got a great position I
thought maybe he should have played uh
this is probably still good too but I
thought it might at least so we had a
question for you one of our viewers said
one of us one of the super GM's called
the French a disaster what's your
opinion on the French at the top level
hold on hold on I got my own problems
here my friend
I got my own problems here my friends
okay so the book that Danny recommended
is called keeping a simple efore
apparently that's by international
master Sulekha and it's on and it's a
course on chest Bowl so you can check it
out if you want to mm-hmm I didn't want
to find out Vishu can hear Danny are you
alpha0 Danny is not whatever I'm not
even gonna get into this now I'm gonna
get into this yes he's still just doing
this in the back he's still doing this
it's hard to talk when these guys are
trying to hurt me so bad they make it
hurt so good ha
some guys wouldn't know if there's
nothing I can do sorry you're dying
that's $50 for this consultation that's
a good one you make it hurt this guy's
making it hurt so good right now I'll
tell you that I got a little grief for
my piece come on Jesse I need you to win
this I'm gonna get our rating up get our
rating up yeah buddy easy for you to say
I'm in a little grief hey that's why
you're the GME reps you gotta you gotta
carry us got carrying this entire club
on chest that calm man I'm getting hurt
all right boys time to buckle up all
right so now we're gonna get to our news
around the world segment of this of this
show
let's see what's new what's new around
the world here so apparently caffeine
wants to live stream games and be bigger
than twitch all right let's see how
that's gonna work caffeine what does
that mean
so there's a so there's a new service
called caffeine and they're gonna try to
like to take on Oh take on to it take on
two-ish so let's see here
let's see it another so in the world of
livestream video games there's twitch
and everybody else agreed course twitch
has the backing of and Amazon but about
this guy's nailing me to the wall bro
come on man
oh no this guy's killing me it's not
good no see for was a terrible move and
I didn't appreciate that he had the
juice man I think I'm hosed so let's see
that the caffeine is wants to attempt Oh
wants to attempt to compete against this
against twitch by in listening a
prominent rapper who's the runt rapper
they're gonna turn this here oh man my
clean sheet looks in danger it's pretty
seriously here
oh it's cardi beasts how husband okay
that's interesting
alright I think I'm ready to say Super
Saiyan well I'm toast
I'm toast what your beginning be bye
Super Saiyan and Super Saiyans crushing
me here man come on rushing come on you
can do it you can do it it's smoking me
man I'm actually just totally host
there's nothing more to say about it
I need some tricks we'll see if Jesse
can get out of this get out of this
predicament he's got himself into and
Trust I can't
oh man didn't I tell you about the the
people who play this exchange that
they're evil they're evil men yeah this
arrest me pretty good so so Anna says if
Danny doesn't want to be on video plug
him and I'm like I'm trying to pull me
in the Mike he won't do it he won't do
it he says the only way he's gonna
communicate is through the chat he's
actually chatting us and singing was
chess club so you want to direct they
can't they can't one person can hear you
because they have great headphones
that's see he's talking to the one
person that has good headphones no he
doesn't know anybody else so somebody
says super saying we'll lose is that
true is that true I doubt it I see
getting hosed here men solitary bat
wants to play a game he I think he
played you yesterday - yes out there
Donna done you rejected my challenge it
hurts so bad that we reject anybody was
it a rated game because we will reject
casual games maybe trying to challenge
it again a radio game we'll see if we
can get to you man I got 38 seconds here
buddy this is a five-minute he's come on
you can do it you can do it trade please
trade queens I'm trying to be work we're
trying I am totally that might have
given me some chances so maybe that way
is there is there a queue or something
there's not so chess comm only lest you
challenge us when we're finished with a
game so you have to be in that sweet
time slot where we're just done with the
game you challenged us and you're the
first one so we will see so yeah
apparently the guy with the great
headphones bit Vishnu was having a
private chat with Danny that's cool
that's cool
and he's Danny with the private
headphone or like the good headphones
that he can actually hear Danny from all
the way in the back are there any
requirements for the challenge to be
accepted rated games
Blizz time control 5 minutes or less
check
I got him on a check buddy I bet he
didn't love it you that loved it
Danny in the back just put out a link to
check on where you can challenge us
that's the link you have to click OK
I think you are confusing Jessie with
that hot hot blonde add just that okay
am i yeah my could a trait could have
traded queens earlier with Queen g5 due
to the mate threat on g2 what rated
games even means so there's a soul what
what I didn't even move and they moved
me Jesus so when you challenge there's
you can select where the for the games
to be rated we're for a casual and non
rated rated basically means if you lose
you lose rating points on chess calm if
you when you game it and we always want
to the threat of either loot losing or
gaining that's what we want we don't
want any casual ones no participation
trophies here you doing okay
no no I know and we need to uh this is a
kid from the show so we need to keep
them from headed he on a low there
I got me in time you know he was pre
moving me or something I couldn't see it
dang oh man that hurt I'm just gonna put
it out there that really hurt let's take
a ten-minute break it'll do well oh did
that be ten-minute but all right 10
seconds my medal for seconds here we go
anything here going on alright alright
Super Saiyan good good job give me a
hand you just beat our resident GM very
good very good
I wasn't expecting I mean it wasn't
expected yeah I thought let's just
actually let's just check it out for a
second he uh you know one one thing I'm
actually thankful for is that I thought
for a moment it felt computery what he
was doing but I think he wasn't he he
wasn't playing with a computer he
because later on he made some funky
moves in his own time pressure well like
here I thought very well played I have a
little grief yeah I have a little grief
here and he I mean I felt like I had to
take this thing and so now he's
definitely better and here and you know
I gotta do something
f4 is about to come or something and so
I knew that g5 was gonna be
controversial I didn't know what else to
do
alright people have to send in their
business here alright challenges sorry
challenges did you win or lose didn't
play pay attention we lost the game
against Super Saiyan ok Super Saiyan
says I thought it blundered Bishop g2
and I looked at Bishop g2 in fact I'll
tell you super saying there was some
cheating going on in the background
because Machuca my took over there was
like hey what about Bishop g2 yeah
people always say and so somewhere
around here he bolted here yeah people
always say Oh Dani so great he's not
he's not on Bishop g2 I was thinking
rook F d1 and I thought I was toast yeah
I think I am - that's - I thought that
was way too much just ignore the bishop
G - all right
who you got challenges somebody cha
Super Saiyan quick question what level
Super Saiyan are are you and you just
have the blonde hair so I'm guessing
that's like what - to level 2 to 3 is
that what it is if I remember correctly
from back in the day you got to even
learn like me what do you mean with the
levels so you know what that know you
know so Dragon Ball Z or Dragon Ball was
the anime which the term Super Saiyan so
say in is a alien race and they have the
power to like become super their hair
turns blonde and like he becomes
stronger that's Super Saiyan and there's
different levels of Super Saiyan so like
we so the first couple levels you get
blonde hair after that I think your hair
turns a lot longer and just say Stark so
I mean it's been like over a decade
since I've seen it so I don't remember
all the other things but uh Danny what
do you you probably know all about this
what do you what are you because I'm of
this no okay
all right
are we gonna get a challenge room from
anybody here we saw a couple of shot
challenges earlier but then we were
going over a game so we couldn't accept
it challenges now so we can accept this
just give it yes if you have a high
rating on chest comm challenges I won't
want to let getting some rating points
here's a question I have here's the
question have so a bunch of people are
like why aren't we playing only chess
and is that because they're just more
familiar with it or is it like the
battle between Lee chess and chest uh
there it I mean there is sort of a
battle between two but I think a
majority that people enjoy leach has
better because there's more functions
yeah we usually always stream on Lee Lee
Lee chess right right I've challenged
Kenna GM lose an online blitz game what
a challenge that challenge here we go
Neil Neil male oh and I had a request to
play E for c4 we're playing it for this
time cool someone wanted me to do it and
I'm gonna do it
BAM that's a good movie acing that lift
before is that what you you usually
don't play E for right here oh look at
least and the guy I played before when I
was a kid yeah I don't know what I'm
doing here
to be for our efore east 6f for jesse
challenge failed
well challenges challenges again in
about eight minutes
how do you get it going this is pretty
so I don't understand why is this a
chess calm thing like we didn't decline
anything but people are getting
challenged decline it for some reason
Danny want to wait weighing on this you
know maybe it was didn't we have a
problem yesterday worse yeah we did who
like Allison upstairs on her account was
like her account said something like you
you're not strong enough to challenge a
GM that was crude that was crude to say
that if that's true then that's bad on
chess calm you can't be doing that to
the people right
now Machuca stalking us in the
background in so we're gonna change some
settings and also I want to change it so
we can get some arrows I need some
arrows let's see a challenge oh yeah so
you if we're currently playing a game
you can't challenge us that's one of the
chests calm things
oh you couldn't you can see it but Danny
walked upon the camera he purposely
turned the camera only to the game so
you can't see him how despicable let's
see here is French McCutchen refuted
that's an interesting question
I played McCutchen many times and you
know it's funny who ended up wasting me
was Danny wrench or chess calm Fame in
the game years ago but basically if you
imagine if you I don't know how many
people can imagine this in their heads
but in the line well and there's this
whole thing where your Bishop does the
dance and instead of going to d2 Bishop
d2 with white plays Bishop e3 various
ways a white can sack the pawn and at
the very least he gets a very strong
initiative and it becomes unpleasant for
black and that's a shame because that
was one of the classical variations I
feel in the French so there we go with
that
trying to play a bishop hh6 I don't tell
them what I'm gonna do Meo male come on
you know I said all right we gotta see
here then that uh so we have somebody
saying GM's can lose blitz games about
forty five years ago I beat zinzie in
the blitz tournament game I was ready
about 1700 of time 45 years ago dude how
old are you
Bishop takes c3 here that's what he did
yeah all right here we go
well he can steal a point I don't know
if he wants it he doesn't want it that's
made me wise
oh I got to be a little careful crime
hey cry you need to be a little careful
buddy he's talking to himself now well
that's isn't brave we're super City
aeration Super Saiyan crush me I lost my
clean sheet
oh this gentleman is 67 Wow props props
on two things I'm living that long well
no problems I'm beating at one feeding
at GM when you were sense to something a
hundred and two continuously playing
chess and even now that's that's great
we have a hundred and one viewers right
now great if any I want to get to 150
viewers so if anybody wants to pull out
their phone and then you know sign on to
our stream to if you feel free to do so
feel free to do so tonight uh Burt
barouche Spinoza that's a great
philosopher you know that you know that
name yeah I don't I'm not a philosophy
guy who's who is that 16th century lived
but is now Belgium and Holland and wrote
kind of like the early Principia
usually called the ethics as you know
the idea to base everything on
principles all right you're confusing me
buddy all right here we go BAM I don't
know what I'm doing I'm just bringing my
bishop back
I need a magical way to bring my other
bishop to magical to do magical things
and I haven't found it yet you can do it
whoo oh he's getting spicy yeah okay
let's let's just let's just talk to the
taco and see what happens hmm didn't uh
Daniel Roberto just said Italy okay cool
is that where you're from
awesome I'll he was from Italy Oh Oh the
Philosopher's were some Italy okay
gotcha
Spinoza no well he's calling you
Jessie's calling you out not from Italy
you know what I didn't call that I was
missing that he's hanging like Wayne but
I can't miss it that anything Wow yeah
this is how happen
I just took this Mianwali give you a big
old head shake on that one and reasons
it resonation let's play over there bat
here we go buddy
you got challenges you can't just say
let's go bro and gotta send us a
challenge in that sweet timeframe where
we just done with the game so - so for
you know help you guys out with that
there's a 30 second gap between what we
say and what you see so basically if
you're thinking of the game is gonna end
in 30 seconds that's when you challenge
us basically I got a question for you
guys and maybe for you - what are some
of the things that leach s does that
people like actually there's this
gentleman that's just talking about
leech s right here solely just he's
saying is probably better with stream
and integration probably automatically
prevent the opponent from looking at
chat video okay well for our purposes is
mainly because so people can challenge
you without when you're in the game so
it'll come up as a like a step yeah
it'll become a sec like we usually have
about like 10 to 20 people waiting on a
wait list
Oh Danny in the backside once we had
like 50 foot 50 or 60 challenges I in
there so you see all of them on a list
and you can pick just for our stream
purposes that's what's what's nice this
is pretty spicy too you see I play a
mean pond okay I did that twice now that
makes sense okay cool cool I feel like I
yeah at some point at some point I was
doing yeah
because I did Chester come have me do
the same thing too and there was a list
of people down below I remember them so
people I could play so how come this
Vishnu guy can hear Danny better than I
can
what is that about how come he can hear
you better not I can I don't get it
oh that's the you you are literally
sitting you're literally sitting like 15
people with four premiere
the vision is the famous guy by the way
Vishnu I'll give you a hand for that you
have great headphones if you can hear
better than me I mean that's that's
awesome this is a real spicy position
here I don't know so so apparently so
like if you guys if any of our viewers
are actually familiar with chess comm
give us a shout how do we apparently
there could be a feature where we have a
wait list of people challenging us but
we don't know how to we don't stream on
chess calm enough to actually know how
to figure out how to do it and also we I
think majority the people here play on
lead a chess anyway so nobody
nope
so Daniel I got his queen oh god it's
caca cool awesome
so yeah nice calmly took it back though
like as if you know he didn't Vishnu
Danny said fifty to sixty so I can't
hear him better than you I wish I had a
mic so I can drop it right now let's
dump duh you got this right 14:07
Oh Salter bat okay so out there bad yeah
you'd think this has to be what's called
a good position right I think this
year's the guy that sided you can get
some easy points from him he's ready to
19 or something maybe we'll try it done
next maybe
Vishnu is to me anyway he's an
interesting guy he started just a little
bit late like I did and you know like I
like myself as well he's got like a kids
and family and stuff and he's improving
this chassis he's on the Twitter land
it's kind of weird that a lot of guys
actually on Twitter you know who like
publicly talk about their chess progress
like what they're doing yada yada and in
a way it's great know part of me is also
like wait a second why aren't you using
this time you got a limited amount of
time buddy what's going on but I think
it's also like there's a community out
there who wants to improve and like
their self but positive feedback loop
right like if you you know kind of like
your where my bike are you on Strama
no no but anyways it's kind of like that
right you posting your rides and you're
saying this is what I did that kind of
thing yeah I mean so social media now
it's just a part of life now you can't
really get rid of it right so everybody
wants to know what everybody else is
doing good ideas all right
see ooh Trading bishops cool cool dude
solitaire Batman you're down you're down
on material why you're trading pieces
because it hurts sometimes to recognize
that you greetings from Latvia greetings
thank you for joining us
hopefully you can come to st. Louis
sometime MSHA see thank you for joining
us all right
one of our viewers asks who's your
favorite tall or Fischer oh I guess I
gotta say Fischer just cuz I I feel like
I understand his games better I'm gonna
be talking about Fischer tonight
actually we're joining a streaming
business at 6:00 6:30 7:30 6:30 time I
guess I get to lectures coming up
tonight they're working me hard here but
I got two lectures six thirty seven
thirty as the first and
I'm gonna talk about Fischer and
solitaire bat real real quick why why is
your name solitaire bad but you have a
picture of a cat on your for your
profile shouldn't be a bat just thrown
out out there just asking a question
game aborted what so ate he went I'm
gonna give him another chance or
something he didn't like about maybe he
wanted me to be white I don't know yeah
well you for alright greetings from
Indonesia
greetings mr. Smith thank you for
joining us he keeps it boarding on me
why are you boarding well why are you
supporting
okay here's Vishnu let's play Vishnu
play Bhishma there we go so South Harry
Vasa thank you he made a stupid blunder
well happens to all of us happens to all
of us
now Vishnu has been experimenting are
basically a play of three the basic yeah
see I know this guy
I don't know I'll call you on that one
yeah yeah I'm gonna play the old school
system and see if he knows what's going
on oh we're talking about something
interesting before Fisher Fisher game Oh
Fisher right so tonight one thing I've
kind of discovered it's really
interesting to me is oh you know I grew
up with Fisher and I had a big book of
like you know all of his games there's a
beautiful book this people are probably
now listen to me are like what a book a
book anyways so this is like back in the
day and um the thing about it
about fisher was is kind of like this
sense of fisher being a universal player
which continues to this day and
something i've discovered recently and
i'm gonna talk about tonight is that the
fact that there's interesting ways in
which he is not in fact a universal
player most specifically the guy really
couldn't play with a space advantage and
people what people did know is like he
had some kind of had this like
mysterious problem against the french
like play terribly against the french
and the thing with the french of course
though is you have to play with a space
advantage and so this is really
interesting thing for me of thinking
about like oh right yeah fisher wasn't
in fact like a universal player and then
the interesting thing beyond that of
course is end to look at other fisher
games openings and talk about like other
instances where he declined to have a
space advantage and the space advantage
itself i just for me is one of the most
fascinating topics of modern chess
because it's complicated and it's kind
of new like a lot of strong GM's now are
are talking about it this is really
interesting you think and it's a little
bit brought on by the computers because
the computers are understanding as well
that the space advantage
he's a whole interesting you're he's
talking on his phone night listen I am
NOT I am actually listen to me man
I am no vote I'm actually so I'm
actually tweeting our next show which
starts in 30 minutes it's actually so
it's international doors direction I
playing the people that doesn't happen
often so we're trying to make sure
everybody knows about it but I am
listening
Volken multitask multitask here we go
one thing about this position on
television ooh
I have no idea what's happening now I
guess here's his critical moment he
needs some special move to get play here
but um might be five like maybe I missed
that god I hope that doesn't wreck me
that would be embarrassing
anyways before I lose it the movie was
supposed to play even though maybe now
he's wrecking me is what was it was way
back win see I said a [ __ ] before it
ephors the right way
now that being said maybe I have what we
call bungled my coconuts or something I
don't know something like that let's see
we have some couple comments here the
cool guys play c5 nowadays against f3
okay
they should take it easy on me buddy
yeah I thought we were friends I thought
we were all getting along here and here
you are you know trying to hurt me when
our viewers asked who's your favorite
chess player and why that's a long
discussion that's a long discussion we
might talk about who the greatest of all
time is maybe next time we happen a lot
more time yeah it's a hard question
whether there's too many too many that's
a long conversation am i doing it next
time
Vista is making it real complicated
right now let's see what our viewers
said why why did the ponic walk across
the street oh man because I wanted to be
a queen ha ha
here's a poem by the way my pieces are a
little funny and he's gonna he's gonna
play 96 and things are gonna get a
little spicy though I have no idea
what's gonna happen
mm-hmm they like spicy stuff it's cool
Vishnu you you said you wanna give us
some free points what's going on right
now yeah resign the game right now
yeah let me sign little live up to your
word man live up to your word so
Spinoza's metaphysical philosophy is the
most important the concept of substance
is more or less the same as mathematical
proof of the string theory
Spinoza was well ahead from his own time
I'm not sure if you agree with that
where you even thought about that but
that's uh see to be a GM don't you have
to memorize chest rather than play with
what you think uh no I don't think so
right why would you
I mean memorizing different lines and
it's important but I don't know no you
don't get that memorizing stuff I don't
know well okay it depends on how you
play like if you're gonna play like
Vishnu and play this f3 move I think you
do want a little bit of what might be
called
Amara's ation like you needed to know
that he for was the move but on the
other hand like efore was the intention
of the whole set up in my opinion anyway
now that said I don't want to make the
vision to think he doesn't have a chance
here he still is in this game that's a
lot you don't have a chance vision you
give up right now resign I think he
needs to show something special though
is the problem he needs a social
something specially under words you're
not special
not special it's not what I said it
doesn't matter what your parents tell
you not special check to the miserable
night I got a tie a distinct time
advantage here oh I didn't know he was
down 46 Wow
Vishnu you're going down man he's got
moved memorize chess and then download
the Internet ha ha ok um let's see here
I decided I'm gonna be boring you're not
I was I was thinking about being spicy
and now I've decided be boring check to
my bishop
let's see here where is this Oh check to
the night
so apparently Twitter is in trouble
because its stock plummeted 20% didn't
know about that that's interesting news
so if you're a stock trader where you
just play for fun keep that in mind
so apparently Amazon is delivering your
packages faster but that's apparently a
takings profits good game Vishnu that's
the first day you know I've gone over a
lot of its own points plug my own show I
do a show every month and I'm gonna do
it next Wednesday and actually we're
changing the time of our stream here
next Wednesday so I'm gonna do a stream
from 3 to 6 and this is all people who
submit their games
Chester calm forum and I go over them ok
it's cool and then I think I'm we're
gonna do the stream a little early on
that day anyways when I was wrong ok
what I'm leading to is Vishnu has been
doing this that for a long time and I
think with a number of other people
who've done it have really improved in
the art of going over your own game yeah
Vishnu said he muted the stream while he
was playing ok Sadie here on any of the
I was talking some smack around Vishnu I
was saying some things he did say thanks
for the game what Jesse blundered on
board that haunts him in his nightmares
every night
wait Jesse what i blundered yeah what
Jesse a blender on board that handsome
in his nightmares every night huh do you
have any blunders that haunt you
oh I have a lot of but the nice thing
about growing old is you just forget you
just forget stuff so that's a nice thing
about growing old as you kind of you
have the ability to forget your blunders
javi Oh Javier Osorio is not gonna
forget this blender though this is a
standard trick once you see it once you
see it you want
alright so Javier we just by remembers
every game I'm up to 1800 for us buddy
I'm slow we're slowly coming up here I
like it I want to see if we can gain in
there to 200 points I'm in next for 20
minutes so we have to average
100 points every 10 minutes that's why I
average if you guys ever study alpha Z
zero for chest moves have you a little
bit no no I don't when you what we mean
by for chest moves but so you just I
think like for example I'm going to talk
a little bit about space at the lecture
tonight the concept of space and I do
think that computers have changed how we
think about space hmm and alpha zero a
couple of those winds that it had it was
sacrifice sacrifice was that one French
position where it's act a full-piece for
space and it was like whoa and that was
that was some next-level stuff so in
that sense sure yeah looks like MSHA
singh here is talking some trash gaining
some rating points before you get to
play him okay okay wow wow I'm not sure
if that that's the tone you meant to say
it but that's the time we're getting so
we're getting to you I'm cha saying
don't worry we're getting to you all
right yeah so he's gonna come up and
then and then we're gonna get him yeah
yeah so I hope everybody's gonna join us
keep on this our channel because we're
gonna have streaming
pretty much the entire and for the next
like what four hours that's right yeah
that's right right yeah we this show
ends in about 15 minutes then we have I
am dorsa come in and play the people
right after that then we have Jesse
cries lecture he's gonna go over some
fissure stuff it's gonna be fun yeah
that's actually two hours so I got
thinner and then we're going to talk
Bobby the second hour so we have a Chess
Club employee Tracy Stewart on the chat
we she says mr. Chen you want a rematch
yes I do we've been playing games all
day actually she doesn't like to admit
it but I've been crushing her you took
Tracy yes
Oh ma'am Traci's tight you don't want to
mess with her she might have B beat me
once you know but that's cool it sounds
to me like you're a little bit denial
about that one time why you got to bring
that up it's just one blunder before
it's the game we played before I have my
morning coffee and I was like I was
groggy
what's the chest movie played before
what's the what date David this is a
this is a kid-friendly show we're not
gonna talk about it talk week it's not
worth it this is the aggression of
Xavier coming at me here Xavier your
loot are you losing Javier's oh wait
Javier's down a piece bro he is down a
piece how are you losing man I tricked
him with a dirty trick there look at the
Queenie five thing yeah oh I want to ask
you so you you lived it I guess close to
Chicago not in Chicago do they still
there's still hustlers on Lakeshore
Drive
oh maybe I haven't been a you have made
elixir drive a while no I it's been
kinda think it was a lot last time I was
there gotta be like almost nine years
ago yeah it's been a long long time
this new says I typically get see five
against my name's of3 yeah that's the
new thing and I was just playing the old
time thing the old thing I think has
some name man I'm like remember the
famous old time player who played that
system
all right so Stanley asked guys when I
come over to my house and play chess oh
well first of all what are you where do
you live
are you insane st. Louis are you in st.
Louis
is this something we have to like fly on
a plane to give us some more contacts
and we'll see will we in biggle
all right I got a question for the
audience ooh that's a little bit related
so back in the day you know before the
Internet this made most of our viewers
probably don't remember this but like we
would get together we would play blitz
chess out of place like Lake Shore and
you had hustlers and you had people like
me who are trying to make a little bit
of money but also just wanted to play
some blitz and now one of the terrible
things I feel is you go to like New York
City say wine is square park and it's
more like these hustlers are just weak
players trying to make a dollar on the
site yeah and they're not playing with
honor anymore they're being like I'm not
gonna pay you or you know I'm not you
have to pay to play you know to use my
board or something back in the day we
had a it was a pretty cool culture here
I'm going to switch it up a little it
was we had a cool culture of you know
warfare Huntly it was like you come and
you're gonna put a little money on the
table and we're gonna play and it's
gonna be kind of hard knuckled honestly
and i feel like yeah we've lost that
change things yeah but I think it's the
internet because you can play now that
you can play all the time on the
internet like that culture of hanging
out at say something like the park in
Chicago it's done yeah I agree I know is
technological age so Matt Damon's not
the real diamond that say man says he's
from Chicago and yes there are hustlers
what are you talking to him he's not the
real Matt Damon I mean he could very
very well be you know I never I'm just
gonna go ahead and assume that the real
Matt Damon doesn't you know the actor
Matt Damon is the
following us on stream if you are that's
great
but like by the way I want to just make
a note this position instead of b6 goko
at the u.s. championship years ago
played 'if I've and I was actually
excuse me he played Knight a5 and then
II 5 which was a really interesting
system that I was totally unprepared for
and lost brutally but I just wanted to
give a shout out for that thing I
somebody says I hate those I pay to play
in Washington Square Park
I like playing online for free yeah
that's where you know Oh Stan Lee's in
Hawaii he wants us to come over and play
chess dude I want to go to Hawaii yes
awesome
ask him what part what island her with
it yeah what Hawaii from the main main
island I would love to go go there I'd
love to go there yeah I have a student
actually and he is in Hawaii if that
makes sense and he's telling me yeah I
gotta go and he's telling me all kinds
of things about it definitely want to go
I know a lot last time I was looking to
take a trip I actually consider Hawaii
but like it was during Christmas time
and I think it's plane ticket prices
over we're outrageous I was like now I
can't do it can't do it but definitely
if I have a chance at definitely going
are there are boring openings deserving
of division when they usually met with
at blitz well you saw I lost to the I
lost to the French exchange today my
friends Eddie you know supposed to give
that derision but you know obviously if
someone cracks you you can't really
complain too much right all right I
think I'm getting a piece here by
snipping that guy
guys 1267 I need I need somebody who's
like 2,500 to play us that's what I need
these get some points
yeah so anyways I spent I think because
chess players are worthless dudes and
they don't want to work I spent a summer
I guess in 1994 playing blitz over there
and on Lakeshore and it was intense man
it was we had some good struggles and I
kind of wish I you know all those people
of course there's no facebook or any way
to connect so you know I lost touch with
all those people of course what are you
doing bro and
what's going on Wow he's just okay
alright well that's interesting
check the miserable King let's see that
uh I think it's awesome what you guys do
here thanks for taking the time for that
peace from DK
thank you very much freedom thank you
very much being able to play online for
free is an amazing thing there's always
something magical about playing over the
board though
well greed I guess agreed going on
cruise ship to Hawaii that should be
cheap I'll look into that that's
actually a pretty good idea but uh I
guess I gotta watch myself here son he's
coming he's coming at me fourth all his
guns is is Jesse's favorite game still
his destruction of knocking ruin 2007
yeah you know I I wrote an article for
us chess ages ago and I didn't call that
actually my favorite game was my
favorite move
I played one move in that game which
actually was it wasn't so much it was a
stunning move as more like a move where
I sense the danger right whereas in
previous versions of myself
jesse 1.0 I wouldn't have felt the
danger right so that's why I don't
mature it was my favorite game but
definitely my favorite move all right
nice try I'm on some of these people
have some games that are hard for ya I'm
gonna guess alright you can come and do
battle let me know dude if I ever go to
Hawaii I'll let you know I'm gonna let
everybody know I'd love to go who why I
think that would be if I move too why I
just check I wouldn't visit I just go to
there to check out I just be a that's it
yeah you can play chess online there
just like you can here go surfing ride
your bike yeah there's some there's some
big volcano or something you can ride to
the your bike to the top it's one of the
biggest climbs in cycling it's like
something crazy like I don't 10,000 feet
I would love to try that actually they
are you are you a rope road biker where
you uh yeah road biker but you know what
if I move to Hawaii I would definitely
get a mountain bike
- cuz I bet that would be cool solitaire
bad let's go all right let's see here
guys it's an amazing oh wait well you
need to get them on whoa you need to get
them down here because we have to play
one game with them right oh we were
supposed to end five minutes early
oh it's fine we won't it's fine we'll do
it next time it's all right Knight f3
that's alright
so one of our viewers said guys this
amazing opportunity to play at GM you're
providing that's what we try to do
that's what we try to do thank you very
much for the compliment and let's go
about the show that's coming up right
now yep sorting about in about 10
minutes
international master doors
direct Shani is gonna be in the studio
to play the people currently student and
chess team member as saying who's
university which is actually just like a
mile down the street from us so we're
really connected there so if you want to
give her a challenge 10 minutes 10
minutes okay we also have other Chess
Club employees here as well one of them
is gonna be Tracy Stewart who was on the
chat earlier I know she's still the one
that I beat all day today she's gonna be
comin in so you can challenge her do you
want to also they got Alison from
yesterday if you joining yesterday
stream Alison is gonna be on the show
today and she's actually what she's here
already ahead of schedule so you know
she's doing a promo for her she'll be
you're gonna be playing around you me if
they challenge okay so she will be so
she will be up for challenges too if you
wish to play her so in about 10 minutes
tuna done which match gave Jesse his
last GM norm do you remember your your
last Jam norm oh yeah yeah that was 2007
at the tournament Foxwoods
and my last game was against Alexander
but the last game where I got it around
early got around despair was against
Alexander shambleau come on in have a
seat have a seat
Allison just asked shaken crash like it
like no you can't leave I'm playing not
a eighty 1400 hours and I'm thank
solitaire bat famous you're probably
gonna have to play solitaire bat to so
don't talk anything about some 1,400
solitaire bat will wreck you I did here
Aditya Chandra how's it going how's it
going how what is it so one one viewer
asks what does it take to beat what is
it how do you become officially rated so
you need to play rated games at rated
tournaments to have an official rating
you have to play so you were just how
about the u.s. you need to join the
United States Chess Federation play
rated game in a rated tournament and I
think you have to play what 25 games to
get an established rating but cool we
have do we have time for no but I have a
question for Alice oh okay and this has
to do with their show so you guys are
gonna I don't get it you guys have four
people at once how is it gonna work yeah
we can take turns playing fun and how
long is it going to go and then I'll be
doing my show at 6:30 just hang out with
a face arrest yeah for six hours yeah
let's see
Stanley Hawaii alright I love it I love
it - so Danny just put the link to - the
stream coming up with the three ladies
are gonna be on the show so if you want
to join in that's our link to it just
gonna accept this guy all right we have
one yeah one less I think he's gonna
he's gonna disconnect or some because
last time char on Oh
this time I know this guy he plays all
the time well because remember the last
time he was this maybe as a connection
problem or something but he continually
like aborted boarded in gotcha well look
at that I'm gonna go for it buddy I'll
see you at leeches yes so the four is
the stream at coming up with the ladies
playing is gonna be on leeches is that
correct Danny okay Li Ches Ches calm so
Danny is making a executive decision
we're just gonna stay on Ches calm so
he's gonna stay on Ches calm all right
challenges that shows calm I hold each s
so you likely chest better too right
yeah so Allison like sweetly chest but
we don't care about that words guy Matt
Damon not going to sleep today nope
you're gonna stay on that you're gonna
stay on the stream all night man it's
gonna be fun
what are you doing kaliesha run I thank
you for the very much for the game today
GM cry what a tremendous honor from jtw
music
I am that was so cool what we had going
on yesterday and uh who's gonna be no
honest but honestly like I I do think
it's cool that you're you're like so I
just are you gonna blame it on the test
comm set up is that we gonna do and
ladies and gentlemen it looks like we
have in an international master dorsa
walking the door right now getting ready
for the stream in a couple minutes so as
soon as we finish this game we're gonna
be turning on to the other oh I think I
just I just blundered my pawn broke what
you did that to me why did you make me
blender the pond telekinesis it's like
one of those like this one wonder it's
wonder we have a chess club here in town
but I haven't got the courage to go yet
why why not you know like when it comes
to chess club's there the zero type is
everybody's a nerd in there every way
you know nobody cares just go in why are
you so scared just go in my elo is 9001
that's uh that's pretty that's pretty
impressive
that's pretty impressive Joyce are you
wanna you wanted to share you want to
see come on in come on door says gonna
replace me I'm gonna transition here
it's fine just leave it oh she's sick
all right
Jesse you're gonna play on the ladies
night stream I have to prep for this
lecture
otherwise I'd love to play I was joking
ladies only but the people who play you
have to be ladies no yeah are you gonna
gonna get this guy it seems like it
should it be already over I have well I
don't know it went away check me in like
30 seconds
Tulisa Ron resigned buddy resigned do us
a favor
resign kaleesh wait what's the name
Kylie Sharon just resign it's what I
call some stream don't know if that was
a genuine I don't know comment or not
but closure are you killing us they're
killing us resign
it's partly my fault because it should
be over and I can't I can't finish I
can't finish the job what if we just is
that an option muted so you can't hear
us
he might waste me I gotta be real
careful my rating is measly 13:58
well there's nobody measly here our cats
allowed to play chess all right please
run that's it buddy
end it it's over Nikki you wanna you
guys are gonna have a good time you guys
have a great time it'll be here but
we're waiting for Jessie Toby what Danny
you didn't have a chair for everybody
okay we had a chair and then we have
this like weird little wooden thing but
it's not you but did you like sitting on
thank you everybody stay tuned for the
next show yeah
[Music]
this has the st. Louis chess club
you